[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit jana
pareigis guten abend schön dass sie
dabei sind und es gibt natürlich am
sport des fußball nations league spiel
mit noch jemand schon so genannter von
mir schauen wir auf die großen themen
heute
die deutschen bauern und der ukraine
krieg hohe kosten für energie und dünger
belasten die erzeuger die
lebensmittelpreise steigen weiter
knapp ist blut in krankenhäusern das
rote kreuz ruft dringend zu spenden auf
deutschland gegen italien in
mönchengladbach in der fußball nation
schläge soll endlich ein sieg gelingen
lebensmittel in deutschland werden noch
teurer davon geht
landwirtschaftsminister erste mir aus
das liegt vor allem am ukraine krieg die
herstellung kostet mehr damit
beschäftigt sich auch der deutsche
bauerntag in lübeck bei dem erste mir
heute war in deutschland sind die preise
für landwirtschaftliche produkte um fast
40 prozent gestiegen hauptursachen die
um 41 prozent gestiegenen
kraftstoffpreise treffen die
landwirtinnen und wird besonders hart
und die kosten für düngemittel sind mit
einem plus von gut 110 prozent geradezu
explodiert einer hebestreit berichtet
landwirt ludwig hirsch berghaus
holsteins zuversichtlich seine
getreidesilos mit einer guten ernte
füllen zu können das könnte ihm
angesichts hoher weltmarktpreise die
einnahmen bringen die er braucht und
seine rasant steigende produktionskosten
zu decken im moment sehen wir dass die
preise für die produktions inputs
einfach an dünger und energie
explodieren wenn landwirte zwar viel
geld für ihre erzeugnisse bekommen aber
gleichzeitig sehr hohe kosten haben dann
ist es ein nullsummenspiel
bauern die nicht rechtzeitig dünger
geordert haben treibt russlands angriff
auf die ukraine in die kostenfalle in
dieser situation wollen sie
vorübergehend jene zwei prozent fläche
beackern die sie laut agrarwende
eigentlich still legen sollen russland
setzt lebensmittel als waffe als schwert
ein und dieses schwert muss sturm
verwerten und wir können es stumpfer
machen wenn wir beispielsweise in
deutschland
diese rund zwei prozent das ist nur da
wo es sinnvoll ist
temporär zur erzeugung von lebensmitteln
freigeben die drohne ernährungskrise
sieht auch bundeslandwirtschaftsminister
erste mehr als problem aber nicht als
grund für eine pause im kampf gegen den
klimawandel
gleichzeitig möchte ich diese ökologisch
wertvollen artenvielfalt flächen für die
biodiversität erhalten und lehne eine
hoch ertrags landwirtschaft mit düngern
auf diesen standorten ab ich weiß
dass nicht alle hier deshalb jubilieren
ganz im gegenteil manche haben mich
deshalb auch persönlich für den hunger
in der welt verantwortlich gemacht die
ukraine krise stellt alle vor große
herausforderungen die landwirte hoffen
auf eine gute ernte auch um die
verteuerung ihrer produktion langfristig
durchzustehen
die bundesregierung will gazprom
germania vor der pleite retten dafür
soll das energieunternehmen mit einem
darlehen in höhe von neun bis zehn
milliarden euro gestützt werden gazprom
germania verfügt über einen erheblichen
teil der gasspeicher und gaspipelines in
deutschland anfang april hatte der bund
die kontrolle über die deutsche tochter
des russischen staatskonzerns übernommen
und die gasversorgung betrifft auch
diese meldung der russische
energiekonzern gazprom kürzt die
maximale liefermenge nach deutschland
durch die ostsee pipeline nord stream 1
um 40 prozent und nennt dafür technische
gründe nord stream ist die bei weitem
wichtigste versorgungsleitung über die
deutschland russisches gas bezieht frank
bethmann für uns einer frankfurter börse
müssen wir uns jetzt sorgen machen dass
das gas knapp wird da darf ich mal das
bundeswirtschaftsministerium zitieren
man beobachte die lage aktuell sei die
versorgungssicherheit weiter
gewährleistet also erstmal entwarnung
keiner muss befürchten dass er morgen
kein warmes wasser mehr hat die
gasspeicher in deutschland sind laut
bundesnetzagentur derzeit wieder über 55
prozent gefüllt komisch mutet an der
geschichte etwas anderes an gazprom
begründet die drosselung mit verzögerung
bei reparaturarbeiten durch siemens
siemens energy hat uns auf nachfrage
bestätigt dass derzeit eine turbine in
einem ganz regulären wartung
sind kanada überholt wird ja aufgrund
der russland sanktionen diese gasturbine
aber nicht an gas kommen geliefert
werden darf auch richtig aber wir
sprechen hier über einen routinevorgang
und grundsätzlich arbeitet eine solche
pipeline mit mehreren turbinen deshalb
ist zumindest zu hinterfragen ob allein
durch diesen vorgang tatsächlich gleich
40 prozent an leistung verloren gehen da
es keinen zeitrahmen zur behebung der
probleme gibt sorgt diese ankündigung
heute aber in jedem fall für zusätzliche
unsicherheit
danke fürs erläutert frank bethmann
in der ukraine tobt unterdessen der
kampf um den dombach die ukrainische
militär mangelt es weiter an waffen mit
größerer reichweite so präsident
selensky die bombenangriffe der
russischen truppen treffen immer wieder
zivile ziele ein bericht von tobias
häfner
1 bombenkrater im flachdach geborstene
fenster und im inneren der geburtsklinik
in der russisch kontrollierten stadt
daun jetzt babys die nach der geburt
behandelt werden hier soll es ein
ukrainisches geschoss gewesen sein dass
kinder leben in gefahr brachte
mindestens zwei babys konnten wir nicht
von den maschinen nehmen nicht mal für
ein paar minuten um zum schutz in den
keller zu geben
in weiten teilen der donbass region
dauern die massiven kämpfe an moskau
veröffentlichte diese bilder um eigene
fortschritte und geländegewinne zu
untermauern
satelliten bilder von zerstörten brücken
in der stadt sehr wie rodeln jetzt kein
ort ist der ukraine krieg derzeit
umkämpfter die anbindung an den rest der
ukraine und an die nachbarstadt lizenz
ist durch drei sprengungen der russen
komplett gekappt schnell folgten offene
drohungen der russland treuen rebellen
die ukrainischen einheiten die in der
stadt stationiert sind bleiben nun sie
haben zwei optionen aufgeben oder
sterben
trotz aller harten gefechten im osten
der ukrainische präsident selensky
schwört seine bevölkerung bereits auf
größere ziele ein
natürlich werden wir die krim
zurückerobern die ukrainische flagge
wird wieder überall tag zu tag über st
und die batterie an jeder russische
offizielle der uns das land genommen hat
sollte wissen sie werden es nie in
frieden behalten dürfen
vorerst aber sind kämpfe um die krim in
weiter ferne wer in der nächsten zeit an
der schwarzmeerküste das sagen hat
könnte sich wohl eher bei den gefechten
rund um person entscheiden
er und der krieg hat millionen familien
zerrissen vor allem ihre kinder wollen
die flüchtenden retten ein ziel
deutschland für die schulen hierzulande
ist das eine große herausforderung und
eine große verantwortung der die kinder
oft traumatisiert müssen eine neue
sprache lernen habe ihre gewohnte welt
verloren helfen können lehrkräfte die
selbst aus der ukraine stammen wie das
funktionieren kann zeigt christas
ungewohnte worte ungewohnte sprache
natalie f cell ska weiß genau dass es
nicht einfach ist für die schüler sie
ist wie sie aus der ukraine geflohen
jetzt ist sie ihre deutschlehrerin erste
schwierigkeit für kinder durch zu lernen
dass sich auf diese linie zu stellen
dass sie müssen deutsch lernen sie haben
gedacht wir sind gekommen für eine zwei
wochen und dann wird gehen nach hause
frontex elster ist eine von mittlerweile
fast 2500 ukrainischen lehrkräften an
deutschen schulen wichtiges bindeglied
zwischen heimat und fremde sehr gut mir
gefällt und kinderkrippen mir
deutschland hat die zulassungshürden
speziell für ukrainische lehrer gesenkt
um die schüler schneller integrieren zu
können da geht es ja nicht nur um eine
verständigung auf ein sprachlicher ebene
sondern eben auch darum dass man ein
bisschen mehr von den kindern und
familien erfahren kann oder jemanden
auch als ansprechpartner hat an
deutschlands schulen sind etwa 130000
ukrainische kinder und jugendliche
angemeldet
alle wollen zurück bildungsexperten
glauben deshalb dass die schüler weiter
online mit ihren heimat schulen in
kontakt bleiben deutsche und ukrainische
schulen digital kooperieren sollen sind
relativ gut digital aufgestellt so dass
die dass viele kinder auch auf der
flucht und auch in den ersten wochen
hier noch in digitalen räumen weiterhin
an unterricht hatten das was natalia
ihren schülern geben will und kann ist
persönliche nähe ich helfe solange sie
mich brauchen sagt sie
es kann jeden von uns treffen täglich
brauchen menschen zusätzliches blut bei
einer op oder nach einem unfall heute am
weltblutspendetag die warnung es gibt zu
wenig blutkonserven in deutschland
während es im jahr 2011 noch rund 7,6
millionen blutspenden gab waren es 2020
nur noch knapp 64 millionen ein rückgang
von 16 prozent
gründe die pandemie und immer mehr
menschen liegen über der altersgrenze
für spender und spenderinnen dabei
werden täglich rund 14.000 blutpräparate
benötigt verena gerät das auto nur noch
an gleich haufen in diesen wagen
verunglückte verlieren webler im april
ihr großvater saß am steuer er war
sofort tot sie selbst kam mit schwersten
verletzungen auf die intensivstation
innere blutungen mehrere organe waren
zerrissen viele knochen gebrochen
letzte gedanke wo ich hatte war echt nur
ich wetter wohl noch heute sterben aber
ich kann mich nicht mehr daran erinnern
irgendwie ich weiß noch ganz kurz über
gerutscht sind und das war's dann auch
schon eigentlich danach ist schwarzes
loch riss intensivstation mehrfach
musste verlieren webler operiert werden
ihr gesamtes blutvolumen wurde ersetzt
ohne transfusionen wäre sie nicht mehr
am leben im klinikum saarbrücken haben
sie immer eine reserve die aber ist
klein immer weniger menschen spenden
dabei ist der bedarf derzeit erhöht
nicht lebensnotwendige operationen die
während der pandemie aufgeschoben wurden
müssen nun nachgeholt werden wir haben
ja coruna bedingt immer wieder
operationen verschieben müssen und wir
haben jetzt die situation dass wir
relativ viel blut brauchen um eben diese
geplanten großen operationen
durchzuführen
ein paar meter über den krankenhausflur
mehr geht noch nicht sie hat die seltene
blutgruppe 0 negativ nur sechs prozent
der menschen haben dieses blut
das war ein riesenglück dass das meine
blutgruppe jahren und das ist genug blut
gab eigentlich für für mich wieder aus
hobby zu holen bei den ganzen habe ich
ja fast zweimal komplette blut aus
meinem körper
verloren sie wird viel geduld brauchen
noch lange ist nicht alles gut aber
verlieren weppler hat überlebt dank des
bluts von fremden
an blutspenden rettet leben welche
blutgruppe für welche empfänger geeignet
ist und welche besonderheiten blutgruppe
null hat das erfahren sie in unserer
heute
trotz protesten sollen heute das erste
mal asylsuchende von großbritannien nach
ruanda abgeschoben werden ihre
asylanträge sollen dann in dem
ostafrikanischen land bearbeitet werden
und selbst wenn sie asyl bekommen dürfen
die schutzsuchenden aber nicht nach
großbritannien zurückkehren wo anders
bekommt dafür mehr als 140 millionen
euro von der britischen regierung scharf
kritisiert wird das vorhaben unter
anderem von den vereinten nationen
andreas stamm berichtet
der flieger nach kigali steht bereit 130
flüchtlinge sollten ursprünglich an bord
gehen höchstens sieben werden es sein
alle anderen haben sich mit eilanträgen
erfolgreich gegen die abschiebung
gewehrt unterdessen kommen weiter
flüchtlinge an im vergangenen jahr fast
30.000 die regierung setzt auf
abschreckung wirft illegalem weg kommt
wird ausgeflogen kann nur in ruanda asyl
beantragen um dort bleiben zu dürfen
was die schleuser tun ist versuchter
totschlag am ort überfahrten über den
ärmelkanal in nicht seetüchtigen booten
dieses geschäftsmodell müssen wir
stoppen
proteste und kritik sind heftig asyl
auszulagern verletze die genfer
flüchtlingskonvention breche
internationales recht die un weisen auf
die schwierige menschenrechtslage in
ruanda hin faire asylverfahren seien nur
schwer zu garantieren
25 englische bischof verurteilen die
praxis in einem offenen brief als
unmoralisch eine schande für das land
keinesfalls strecke es ab erklärt einer
der ausgeflogen werden soll in einer
abschiebe einrichtung wartet ibrahim aus
syrien er wollte zu frau und kind die
schon in london sind darf telefonieren
wenn sie mich nach ruanda schicken werde
ich wiederkommen bis ich bei meiner
familie bin wirklich nichts aufhalten
ich bin bereit dafür zu sterben
ibrahim ist nicht mehr auf der liste für
den umstrittenen flug der am späten
abend abheben soll bis dahin geht das
juristische tauziehen um jeden
einzelfall weiter benötigt startete man
mit nur einem flüchtling erklärt die
regierung die mit aller macht ein
exempel statuieren will
gespannt wurde auf dieses urteil
gewartet heute hat der bundesgerichtshof
entschieden dass das judenfeindliche
relief an der stadtkirche wittenberg
nicht entfernt werden muss die
begründung es gebe eine erläuternde
bodenplatte und ein aufsteller dieses
relief aus dem 13 jahrhundert von einem
schandmal in ein mahnmal umwandeln
würden über die reaktion auf das urteil
christian von rechenberg
in stein gemeißelte antisemitismus das
sei die wittenberger so entfernen muss
die kirche sieht dennoch nicht der bgh
entschied heute gegen den kläger es
fehlt an der für einen derartigen
anspruch erforderlichen
gegenwärtigen rechtsverletzung 700 jahre
alt ist die plastik an der fassade der
wittenberger stadtkirche sie zeigt juden
in intimer nähe zu einer sau
brutalstmögliche und gewollte
beleidigung damals der kläger selbst
jude fühlt sich auch heute beleidigt
weil
die jugend sei an einer kirchenmauer
eine ganz andere
propagandistische wirkung
antisemitische wirkung hat in wittenberg
gibt es eine kommentierung eine info
tafel die die plastik lehrt sowie eine
bodenplatte als erinnerung an die
judenverfolgung in deutschland das
ensemble mache aus den schandmal ein
mahnmal so der bgh die fortdauernde
rechtsverletzung somit beseitigt der
zentralrat der juden in deutschland ist
mit dem urteil einverstanden nicht mit
der infotafel die sei zu klein und es
fehle ein schuldeingeständnis
die in rede stehende schnee plastik war
an der kirche von martin luther
angebracht die evangelische kirche hat
sich sehr klar von den antisemitischen
aussagen martin luthers distanziert aber
genauso deutlich erwarte ich hier auch
eine distanzierung von diesen schmäh
plastik wie umgehen mit dem kulturellen
erbe mit antisemitismus und rassismus an
kirchen durch denkmäler in straßennamen
das urteil heute ein grundsätzlicher
beitrag man kann also sich von einer
plastik oder einem solchen relief
distanzieren aber es ist natürlich eine
frage des einzelfalls ob das tatsächlich
auch geschehen ist der kläger will nun
das bundesverfassungsgericht anrufen
knapp zwei wochen vor dem g7 gipfel auf
schloss elmau in bayern hat die
bundespolizei ihr einsatzkonzept
vorgestellt dazu gehören auch
grenzkontrollen wie etwa zu österreich
reisende müssen aber an allen deutschen
grenzen mit stichprobenartigen
kontrollen rechnen damit soll die
anreise möglicher gewalttäter aus dem
ausland verhindert werden
er war einer der besten schlagzeuger der
ddr fast vier jahrzehnte lang trommelte
er bei den puhdys jetzt ist klaus
scharfschwerdt mit 68 jahren an krebs
gestorben
seit 1979 war mitglied bei den puhdys
mit ihm veränderte sich der sound mehr
in richtung hard rock die puhdys waren
eine der erfolgreichsten bands der ddr
2016 lösten sie sich auf
[Musik]
ja und jetzt können wir zur fußball
nations liegt norbert fußballfans zehn
jahre schon minuten runter er in 90
minuten ist es soweit anpfiff
deutschland italien ja nicht nur wir
beide hoffen dass nach dem apfel das dfb
team als sieger vom platz geht ein spiel
bei dem wirklich alles drin ist das
fünfte unentschieden in folge bei einem
sieg könnte deutschland tabellenführer
werden bei einer niederlage
tabellenletzter
jochen breyer in mönchengladbach welche
bedeutung hat dieses spiel für die
deutsche mannschaft
eine ziemlich große wird es ist zwar nur
die nations liegt der wettbewerb selbst
hat jetzt nicht die ganz große relevanz
aber in gut fünf monaten steht ja eine
weltmeisterschaft an und der
bundestrainer ist ehrlich gesagt alles
andere als zufrieden mit dem
leistungsstand der mannschaft im moment
letzten samstag gab sie an eins zu eins
in ungarn damit hat die mannschaft jetzt
vier spiele lang nicht mehr gewonnen und
die schöne aufbruchstimmung die
entstanden war als hansi flick
übernommen hat als bundestrainer die
droht gerade flöten zu gehen deshalb
wäre es enorm wichtig endlich mal wieder
zu gewinnen dann auch noch gegen einen
großen namen gegen italien im klassiker
um dann mit einem guten gefühl in den
urlaub zu gehen aber vor allem auf die
wm schauen zu können wir melden uns um
20.15 hier aus mönchengladbach dann muss
später ja danke nach mönchengladbach
zu den beiden letzten playoff finales
zur fußball weltmeisterschaft heute
abend spielt costa rica gegen neuseeland
der sieger wird deutscher gruppengegner
in katar sein und das vorletzte wm
ticket löste gestern abend australien
gegen peru nach 120 torlosen minuten
wird andrew redmayne eingewechselt
australiens keeper fürs elfmeterschießen
und der wird zum titel held aus down
under redmayne pariert den letzten
peruanischen elfer und australien
erfolgreicher start für tennisspielerin
andrea petkovic beim wta-turnier in
berlin die 34 jährige bezwang die
frühere wimbledonsiegerin und aktuelle
weltranglisten zehnte
jo großer aus spanien mit 7 zu 6 6 zu 4
damit ist die darmstädter sind als
einziger deutscher ins achtelfinale
eingezogen
läuft für die petko das was vom sport
dankeschön abad läuft auch beim wetter
sonnig und warm geht der juni weiter
wann ist wie heiß wird das erfahren sie
gleich von katja horneffer das heute
schon mal können sie in der
halbzeitpause des nations league spiels
deutschland italien um 21.30 sehen mit
marietta slomka auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
guten abend temperaturen von 40 grad
sind in nordafrika auch zu dieser
jahreszeit nicht ungewöhnlich aber in
spanien ist das schon was besonderes
mitte juni und dann wird's auch nachts
kaum noch kühl wir sprechen von
tropischen nächten wenn die nacht
temperaturen nicht unter 20 grad sinken
das ist am mittelmeer ganz verbreitet
der fall und hier im süden spaniens
sinken die werte in der nacht zum teil
nicht unter 25 grad da ist es bei uns
doch deutlich angenehmer bei der nacht
temperaturen sinken auf 14 bis fünf grad
und meistens der himmel klar nur über
den nordosten ziehen einige wolkenfelder
hinweg das wird sich auch morgen über
tag kaum ändern und mit auflandigem wind
liegen die temperaturen an den küsten
von nord- und ostsee morgen bei 18 bis
20 grad im binnenland geht es dagegen
auf 24 bis 29 grad drauf und an mosel
mittel und oberrhein werden sogar 31 bis
33 grad erreicht und dann wird es von
tag zu tag er noch wärmer am donnerstag
erwarten wir einige regenschauer oder
kurze gewitter aus den alpen heraus oder
auch in den östlichen mittelgebirgen
danach geht es trocken und sehr heiß
weiter der höhepunkt wird wohl am
samstag erreicht bis zu 37 grad guten
abend